Para aprender idiomas
tenemos que dominar lo básico.
¿Es verdad? No.
Noticias de última hora:
No es posible dominar lo
básico, sobre todo al inicio.
Vamos a continuar a cometer los
mismos errores durante largo tiempo.
Entonces no tenemos que preocuparnos
con esta inútil voluntad de dominar lo básico.
¿Qué es lo básico?
Y yo lo digo de mi experiencia
como aprendiente de idiomas.
¿Qué es lo básico?
Las palabras, por ejemplo,
¿que son las palabras básicas?
Muchos libros que enseñan
idiomas empiezan con, yo
no sé, los colores, los números,
pero esas cosas son muy difíciles.
Hay palabras con más frecuencia,
pero de todas maneras, estas palabras
las vamos a encontrar con alta frecuencia.
Entonces, vamos a aprender
esas palabras más fácilmente.
Pero ciertas palabras van a seguir ser
difíciles de acordarse de esas palabras,
¿no? La misma cosa con las estructuras.
Para mí, por ejemplo, ahora estoy
hablando en español, que no hago mucho.
Entonces voy a
Cometer errores básicos.
Pero si hablo más, pues cometería
menos errores básicos, ¿no?
Entonces lo básico es un
concepto muy subjetivo.
Y de todas maneras, hay un orden
natural de adquisición de un idioma
según estudios que ha hecho,
por ejemplo, Steven Krashen, y este orden
natural de adquisición puede depender
del idioma que estamos aprendiendo
y de nuestro idioma.
Por ejemplo, un italiano que
está aprendiendo español,
pues será más fácil, ¿eh?
Muchas cosas de la gramática.
Y también las palabras son parecidas
a las palabras o estructuras en italiano.
Entonces, hay un orden natural que es
diferente, pero por alguien que está
aprendiendo, por ejemplo, inglés,
eh, sabemos todos que el inglés, la
tercera persona del presente tiene
un "S", por ejemplo, i go, you go, he GOES.
Pero esto es muy difícil.
Es una cosa gramatical básica, pero
los no nativos continúen a cometer
este error muy simple porque tenemos
que construir hábitos nuevos.
Y este se hace según un orden natural.
Se hace a lo largo, no?
Entonces, deliberadamente, tratar
de aprender, dominar lo básico
es inútil y no ayuda, porque todo
el tiempo que estamos tratando
aprender, por ejemplo, las
conjugaciones, es tiempo que yo no voy
a utilizar para escuchar más, leer
más, hablar más, para que mi cerebro
se acostumbre al nuevo idioma.
Y por esa razón que en LingQ, por ejemplo,
yo siempre empiezo con las mini historias
que son fáciles, con mucha repetición y de
esta manera se crea una idea del idioma.
Porque finalmente podemos enfocarnos
en lo básico después de que tengamos una
idea del idioma y podemos al fin, después
de mucha experiencia con el idioma,
tratar de perfeccionar, por no
decir dominar, porque vamos a
continuar a cometer errores.
Es muy importante no tener un
sentimiento de frustración.
Y si después de mucho tiempo estamos
cometiendo errores básicos, porque
este es el caso mío,
creo que es el caso de la mayoría
de la gente que aprende los idiomas.
Entonces más importante es mantenerse
activo, seguir escuchando, leendo, gozando
del idioma y poco a poco va a mejorar.
Y si después quieres concentrarte
en ciertos aspectos de vocabulario
o de gramática, puedes hacerlo y
sería más fácil asimilar esas cosas,
Explicaciones, patrones porque finalmente,
el fundamento del idioma no es como
construir una casa con ladrillos.
No es no como hay un fundamento
Y después vamos a
construir el segundo piso,
Tercer piso. No. Es como
un plato de gelatina.
Las cosas entren y salen.
Aprendemos y olvidamos.
Y es por esa razón que en LingQ
no medimos el progreso de los
estudiantes, porque ésto es difícil.
Algunas veces tenemos la impresión
de progresar y después no.
Pero lo que podemos medir
Y lo más importante es el
nivel de actividad de cada uno.
Y si el pendiente sigue activo
escuchando, leyendo, con el tiempo,
pasando con el idioma, con una actitud
positiva, es seguro que va a progresar.
Entonces mi consejo, como una persona
que ha aprendido a diferentes
niveles muchos idiomas, es que las
cosas básicas no podemos dominarlas.
(Tenemos que) continuar a estudiar, volver, leer
cosas interesantes y poco a poco
vamos a acostumbrarnos al nuevo
idioma, sin molestarnos con esta
voluntad de dominar lo básico.
Hasta luego.